Una pregunta
cuál es su secreto para tener tanta
energía
mi secreto es la libertad de las mujeres
[Música]
en los siglos 17 y 18 los hombres
obligaban a las mujeres a llevar corsé y
zapatos diminutos
de trataban a las mujeres como muñecas
odio esta idea le ponen furioso con
todas estas historias
Así que ahora siempre estoy del lado de
las mujeres
libertad una palabra pronunciada por
todos los diseñadores que acudieron a
París para presentar su colección ready
to Where del verano 2023 liberar los
cuerpos y las de todas las formas de
restricciones y dictados
al igual que yoyi yamamoto y de nori
kumakiri trabaja en Tokio para él la
libertad consiste en encontrar nuevas
formas de conexión entre lo masculino y
lo femenino la parte delantera y la
trasera lo simple y lo complicado que
traje civil y el uniforme militar
el mundo en el que vivimos actualmente
es muy oscuro
[Música]
y entonces tuvieron esta idea beautiful
people
de intentar cambiar esta prenda de
vestir de supervivencia pero de una
manera más alegre y sobre todo lo que me
parece interesante es el hecho de que
sea intercambiable que puedas hacer
varios conjuntos esta chaqueta se
convierte en dos chaquetas
[Música]
aquí llevaba una parca de aspecto
bastante clásico verde como el resto de
la colección que de repente se convierte
casi en un vestido de noche naranja
y esa es la chispa de la colección
con la colección
como sitraorece define como emprendedor
social a través de su asociación lessa
telépaga y xian creó una escuela de alta
costura en los suburbios de París él
también se ha tomado la libertad de
rehacer un uniforme el de los
recolectores de basura
tuve un padre que era recolector de
basura todos los padres muchos de los
padres de mi barrio eran recolectores de
basura que habían trabajado duro toda su
vida quería rendir homenajes a esta
profesión que madruga cada mañana para
limpiar las calles de París Luego
pasamos muy bien Me sumergieron el mundo
de los recolectores de basura en su
entorno se trata de un proyecto en
colaboración con la ciudad de París
descubrí muchas cosas para llegar a una
colección que es muy urbana que es muy
diferente de lo que solía hacer
hemos mantenido un poco el espíritu de
la alta costura pero hoy es muy colorido
muy brillante muy llamativo y
fluorescente
es muy ecológico encontramos el denim
japonés que nos gusta esta temporada y
mucho más denimmy
también vestidos de niños piensas que se
pueden transformar y ajustar qué más de
hecho el uniforme del recolector de
basuras se ha convertido en una prenda o
moda
para ello
Moshi traoré pidió consejo a ludovic
leué una estrella de las redes sociales
que no deja de alabar su profesión
pero ya sabes desde que era niño pensaba
en el basurero porque veía a esa gente
recogiendo a esos hombres recogiendo
esas canecas nuestras canecas Y ahí
estaba yo Detrás de mi arbolito los
estuve observando y luego llevé mi bolsa
para ayudarlos e incluso recogí las
colillas de mis hermanos y hermanas no
solo hice amigos sino que les mostré que
las canicas existen es muy importante
tendemos a olvidarnos Pero mira como
Aquí estos contenedores están resaltados
en Isabel Magan la libertad de afirmarse
forma parte del ADN de la marca que se
fundó en 1994 Libertad para vestir Como
quieras como chica o como chico sexy o
no
representa la libertad
la felicidad la alegría
la mujer en su plenitud es siempre una
fiesta
es una gran artista
a mí personalmente me encanta Isabel y
me encanta todo lo que hace y siempre es
cómodo estoy emocionado por ver el
espectáculo porque las chicas son sexys
sexy
es obvio que ustedes francés
[Música]
Libertad Revolución
de hecho es una feminidad asumida pero
con cierta discreción
de hecho tenemos una expresión en
francés que nadie más tiene
Y eso es algo indescriptible es esa
despreocupación sergi pero no demasiado
poder pasar por todos los sitios por
todas las épocas estar siempre en su
sitio y creo que es muy importante
cuando se puede dar eso a una mujer a un
hombre también a través de la moda
es la confianza la confianza en uno
mismo absolutamente
ponerse tacones altos o bajos cambiar o
no cambiar de ropa seguir o no seguir la
moda Ahí es donde reside nuestra
libertad como mujeres u hombres
liberados
[Música]